sera chaud très chaud avertit
l’organisation des Nations Unies la
chaleur deviendra si intense dans
certaines régions que les humains ne
pourraient plus y vivre l'ONU en
collaboration avec la Croix-Rouge a
recensé dans un rapport les vagues de
chaleur elle conclut qu’elles sont
responsables de certaines des
catastrophes les plus meurtrières jamais
enregistrées
à vous le chef de l'agence humanitaire
rappelons qu'en Europe en 2003 près de
70 000 personnes sont mortes en raison
des températures extrêmes en 2010 c'est
55000 en Russie et cette année encore
des régions ont suffoqué à Londres le
mobilier urbain a fondu au soleil 33
jours de canicule consécutifs en France
des rivières asséchées dans le sud-ouest
de la Chine et les plus affectés sont
majoritairement les plus vulnérables
Nestlé Anne-Claire
en 2021 le Canada atteint un record de
près de 50 degrés Celsius à l'étude en
Colombie-Britannique le pays est mal
préparé à l'augmentation des
températures selon cette chercheur
parce que
se trouve tard parce que on voit pas les
gens qui sont affectés par les îles aux
chaleurs d'ici 2080 des vagues de
chaleur s'abattront dans le sud du pays
principalement le long de la frontière
américaine et la vallée du Saint-Laurent
Toronto et Montréal
et le Canada doit s'attendre à recevoir
des réfugiés climatiques les gens sont
entiers de la migration vers le Canada
mais on voit peut-être pas maintenant
mais dans le futur
à moins d'un mois de la cop27 l'ONU et
la Croix-Rouge souhaite une prise de
conscience mais aussi un financement à
la hauteur du défi ici Marie-José paquet
como Radio-Canada Montréal